yeah i went to the police five times at
least
five or six now um they just said
there's nothing we can do about it
what there's nothing we can do about it
those are their exact words
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantly
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
guest today is a grooming gang survivor
dr lahill welcome to trigonometry thank
you very much for having me it is a
pleasure to have you here for just for
people watching who know us as
kind of jokey and bantery given the
subject matter we're not going to do
that too much today even though
we banter with you off the screen and
yeah and you enjoy
that and we enjoy that but just we got
to do justice to what we're talking
about so
for people who don't know your story and
maybe we have a lot of people from all
over the world watching as well
uh they don't know what grooming gangs
are they
for some people haven't heard it and
actually i don't even like that term
particularly because i think it conceals
what these things really are so tell us
first of all
what they are and then we'll get into
your own story
after that okay um
well i have my own definition of
grooming gang crime and
it's something that i'm hoping that more
people will accept as a
accepted definition because it's a
culturally agreed
idea you know what comes to mind when
people say grooming gangs
that it's a racially and religiously
aggravated
rape and group or network
based rape and very often of underage
girls but it can be older girls
girls as well and young women and where
does it mainly happen because
the words or the name of the town that
is most commonly associated with it is
rotherham
is it just in the north or does it
happen all over the uk
well it's all over the uk there's lots
of different towns now that have been
named has been involved there's you know
there's
burnley blackburn you know there's
oxford
um really there's very few big major
cities that haven't had some sort of
grooming
gang scandal and the numbers now
estimated over the last 40 years
possibly half a million victims
half a million half a million victims
over the last 40 years
yeah right the predominantly white
victims and the perpetrators are
predominantly
asian muslim yeah we'll definitely get
into that so we're not going to shy away
from that at all
um half a million yeah
that's i i've my jaw is
slightly a gape and i think i i i
want to see that no certainly not
um i guess the question is if
half a million girls have been abused
why is there not a national scandal why
do we not know about this
well it is a national scandal and in
rotherham there have been here there
have been
numerous reports after reports that have
been looking into it and highlighting
this type of crime and
there's been national crime agencies
have been doing an investigation of
historic cases over the past
15 years and they've
reopened a lot of cases and looked to
bringing perpetrators to justice
i think maybe about 20 25 perpetrators
have been brought to justice in
rotherham but there's over
a thousand under investigation by the
national crime agency in operation
stovewood
itself okay well let's get into that
but uh before we do i i said i think
it's important we get your
your own story sure yeah yeah so you
were
a victim of of one of these gangs in
rotherham
yeah yeah uh and just talk us through it
okay well um i'll just say my background
a little bit as well first that you know
i'm a medical doctor i'm a mum you know
my my um
story started over 20 years ago and yeah
i was
i was targeted as a in my late teens
um so i had a sunny muslim boyfriend and
um that led on within a few weeks to
becoming a very
controlling obsessive um
religiously charged relationship
and then been taken to different houses
different flats above takeaways
around the area rather than sheffield
bradford um
to be raped beaten strangled
suffocated tortured
almost drowned to death suffocated to
death and
you know really really brutally harmed
you know covered in bruises most of the
time and that lasted over a year
so so that is so your experience lasted
collectively over a year
essentially and i mean the next question
i'm going to ask is how did you possibly
get out of that awful situation
um well i tried to escape i tried to get
away
um a lot of it i was hiding from my
parents because i was very very scared
that they were going to get killed
because i was there there were threats
to kill my parents
threats to kill me um
and but i did try and move tried to get
away and
my perpetrator just found me very easily
and
still taught me basically to find me and
um broke into my house and trashed the
house and
um planned an honor killing
which he persuaded some of his friends
to
join in with and i survived and
attempted
on a killing um with multiple
lacerations and fractures
and then i was in hospital for over a
week and at that point the police told
my parents to move me away
and change my name which is what they
did and that's how i got out of it
and with this horrible situation lasting
i mean a year
is a long time anyway but a year of of
that kind of
thing is is a lifetime right and
uh did you approach the police
yeah yeah i went to the police five
times at least five or six now
um they just said there's nothing we can
do about it what
there's nothing we can do about it those
are their exact words
i you so you did
i mean were you explicit in what you
told them so you said i'm being raped by
this i describe really horrific horrific
things
and they just said there's nothing we
can do about it did they offer an
explanation
as to why there was nothing well i said
i'm sure these are crimes
you know i was a teenager at the time
but i didn't know that these were crimes
um
i wasn't sure that it was rape even
though my perpetrator said
we're going to gang rape you we're
raping you yeah they used the word rape
but i wasn't sure that it was because i
didn't know because it was my boyfriend
um so i didn't really understand what
the law was around that
but um well the police should have
understood that they should have
understood yeah yeah yeah so you
you go to them repeatedly and they and
every time this is what they say
this is another thing we do about it
yeah why do you think that was
um
culture at the time at the time there
was a culture of
inaction i think that was what the
review found that within the police at
the time there was a culture of inaction
motivated by what um
partly by the belief that
is your word against theirs and a lot of
sexual crime
that you know how do you prove what went
on in a room where there were no other
witnesses
and where people are denying what you
say happened
but surely ella there were physical you
describe physical lacerations to your
body when yeah when there is a crime of
that nature there are
there is damage that is inflicted upon
the body yeah
yeah i did you know i'm still at scars
from lacerations
and um you know it's all documented the
fractures
all had x-rays it's all documented in
the medical notes
i've read my medical notes and the nurse
says you know this
this patient says that her ex-boyfriend
has tried to kill her five times
and that he's tried to kill her and so
it's all in it's all documented
and the when i heard about the
um the j report in 2014 that's when i
re-reported it to the police because i
i well i didn't report it sorry i made a
complaint to the
ipcc the independent police complaints
commission which is now the iopc
and the independent office of police
complaints i think
so they investigated it and they found
that there was gross negligence
but they couldn't prosecute or take any
disciplinary action against the police
officers because they said they couldn't
identify the names of the police
officers
or that they'd already retired why
couldn't they identify the names of the
police officers
missing notes oh convenient
i i think you know we've prepared for
this interview
we've talked to you in advance we've
listened to your previous interviews
we've
read about it we've read your articles
you've written some really excellent
articles including one for the
independent
but the stuff you're saying you're
saying it to our faces now and i
i literally cannot believe the things
you're telling me you went to the police
five times yeah
with physical wounds and evidence saying
that
this man was abusing you in this way and
the police said there's nothing we can
do
like i i don't think there's anyone
who's listening to this or watching this
who could conceive of that being true
even though we know that it is
yeah it's true yeah it just it's i mean
it's
shocking and i i was i was absolutely
gobsmacked i think that's the word i use
i was gobsmacked to hear the police
telling me
there's nothing we can do about not even
question the perpetrator not even
you know take photographic evidence or
anything
right so i i was gobsmacked to to hear
that there's they felt completely
powerless
and now i think over the years i've
learned a lot more about what is
happening behind the scenes with
education and police force
with um the way that the police have
been
restricted and limited in what they can
do so i do understand a lot more
of why those decisions were made at that
time okay
tell us about that well
um uh
a lot of it's to do with race and
religion which a lot of people don't
really like talking about and they don't
like
to hear it um but this is why i'm
i feel um compelled to talk about
what's happened and what is still
happening
um because people need to hear it from
survivors that these are racially and
religiously aggravated crimes
that when i was being beaten i was being
called a white slag a white [ __ ] a
white [ __ ]
that over and over again the references
to my whiteness was
always at the forefront of my
perpetrator's mind
and that that was always linked in with
religion and his idea of what
a good muslim was and a bad non-muslim
was
or a good believer and a bad unbeliever
even though i was a christian
even though i have my faith in god i
pray you know i believe
in heaven and hell i believe in good and
bad um good and evil
so but in the minds of these grooming
gangs um if you're not covered down to
your ankles down to your wrist if
the hem of your top doesn't cover your
knees then you're asking to be raped
or um you know if you're if you're not
washing in a way that you should wash as
a
muslim if you're not if you're eating
pork you're unclean
you're dirty if you use a knife and fork
you're dirty
if you don't eat your food with your
hands it sounds like i couldn't never
quite understand that the opposite way
around but um
so there's lots of narratives within
these grooming gangs which
make um hatred of white people
a justification for what they're doing
and
also scriptural things like you know
we're allowed to do this we're permitted
to do this to you once you've started
your periods so we can't do it to you
and before you start your periods we
have to do
which is another type of sexual
molestation
and which doesn't involve penetration
okay so i mean it's just
a lot to take in what you've just
explained
yeah um and i remember talking to you
before the interview started in that
and now correct me if i'm wrong that the
police don't see this as a race crime or
a race-based crime
could you explain maybe if i'm wrong if
i am and
just go into a little bit further
what how the police have been trained
for a long time
is to preserve interracial relations to
um not raise any racial hatred to not
accuse people of
um of of doing something in the name of
religion
which could cause anti-muslim prejudice
or
anti-islamic prejudice so
this is the way that police have been
trained for a long long time years and
years and years
um so
they're looking at it from completely
the wrong way around they're looking
from a perpetrator's perspective
rather than from the victim's
perspective where the victim has been a
victim of identity-based violence
where they've been attacked because of
their race and they've been attacked
because the religious status which is a
non-muslim
or christian or sikh or hindu or
buddhist or whatever
and whatever it is that the liberties
feel
is the religious justification for that
person deserving punishment
wow and so they simply they can't they
won't they refuse to acknowledge it as a
race-based crime
even though you've given them evidence
of it even though the part of the reason
they they committed these
unspeakably awful acts upon you was
because the fact that you were white and
therefore they
felt emboldened and empowered to do that
because
and they still weren't no i think
the way that the system is has been set
up
it has been set up to have protected
groups
and white people and non-muslim people
are not a protected group according to
the these are current police guidelines
for hate crimes
and so certain protected groups like
muslims immigrants
refugees jews i'm fine then
trans yes you're safe
[Laughter]
i'm coming out on this particular
episode
and you're a minority of the world yeah
absolutely oh yeah
mixed race mixed race yeah and a half
latin american
he's gammon yeah yeah it's all gap this
is 100 pure brexit
i think you're both cancelled by now
yeah
but i get your point there's lots of
groups that are protected under this
categorization
but but white people are not and you're
saying that's current guidelines there's
current guidance
so let me put it very pointedly to you
if what happened to you was to happen to
another young woman today yeah and she
went to the police
and said this is what's happening to me
yeah and i think it's because
i'm white yeah they would still
behave in a similar way some police
forces they would not recall that as a
hate crime
but in some police forces i mean people
think of met police as the whole of the
uk it isn't that's just one police force
and there's
i think it's 23 or 25 different police
forces all over the uk and they all have
different
management structures and training
systems
um it's all over seen by the college of
policing but you know there's a slight
different culture in each
in each part of the country so so some
of them probably
are recording anti-white hate crimes now
um but looking at last year's
hate crime statistics there was none
that we haven't got any hate crime
statistics for anti-white hate crime
we haven't got any hate crimes today for
anti-western hate crime
and i would say that when we talk about
anti-western hate crime
anti-white hate crime we need to include
the anti-western as well because now we
are getting
well we always have had the brown
people who are being attacked for being
too white so they're being called
coconuts they've been called uncle toms
you know the black people who don't fit
in with the
specific cultural belief of what they
should be for being black
yeah according to certain groups you've
just described every every ethnic
minority guest on trigonometry
yeah as you know yeah pretty much so uh
well i want to balance this up a little
bit just in terms of
i i want people to know about you which
i know about you that you're not someone
who's
driven by antipathy towards other groups
of people even
even even muslims which frankly you know
you'd be forgiven for even if
even if it's not accurate to say that
this is all muslims
people i think would understand if you
had some kind of antipathy but you don't
which is incredible not so i mean for my
christian faith
my very strong belief is love your enemy
so love your enemy bless those who curse
you and do good to those who spitefully
use you so that is what i fall back on
again and again and it's been a chosen
decision
that you know these people who have made
me their enemy or they are my enemy
they're attacking me and it's
they're identifying me as an enemy that
they have to harm
um i will not hate them
i will not hate all muslims not at all
in fact i will love them
i will i will make a determined choice
to love them
and for them to be my friends and for me
to you know cook meals for my friends
and
you know take care of them look after
them check on their kids their families
everything um
i will not be driven to hate anybody
because of their color of their skin or
their background or their race or
religion
age gender sexuality you know
that that i think is really part of
this part of my faith which is
incredible
i mean it's i mean it's so powerful the
fact that it's
considering the the extremities of your
experiences
the fact that you would then make a
concerted effort to
make that choice is you know it's it's
phenomenal really
it's been quite easy i have to say
because
i've met some absolutely wonderful
people like in my career training as a
doctor
through medical school through working
hospitals
just absolutely fantastic like my
friends there's nepalese
thai chinese um
lebanese iraqi indian
sri lankan these are my close close
close best friends that i've had for
years and years
so um it hasn't been hard to love them
at all to be fair and my pakistani
friends as well you know
the main charity that i support is that
pakistani it's in pakistan it's a
christian charity
and that's through my friends in the
church
um but for me it gives me peace
to love people um no matter what
that gives me peace so when i see like
this black lives movement
and i see a lot of the people on the
streets and they've got injustice and
injustice is horrible and racism is
horrible
to be a victim of any kind of
identity-based violence
is devastating and if it's been
perpetuated through generation
after generation you know or it's been
ingrained in your schooling or you know
you've experienced it on the street
throughout years
that is awful and you know it's very
traumatizing and it can be compacted by
lots of historical things as well
um so
i do think identity race violence is
terrible and
but for these black lives matter people
to go through
the streets chanting no justice no peace
no justice no peace
what i'm seeing is a perpetuation of no
peace
and the only way that justice has been
offered to them is through
what appears to be revenge at the moment
you're absolutely right
the reason i bring up this point is i
think
let's just be straight about it a lot of
people feel that the issue of
identity has become very toxic and you
know this
and a lot of people feel
and this is because of course as you can
i think you'd agree
identity politics for minorities has now
pushed a lot of people into a corner
where some people are starting to go
well what about my identity as a
straight white man or whatever
whatever it might be or a straight white
woman or whatever and so
to talk about anti-white hate crime
yeah to a lot of people that that
triggers their inner alarm bells of
you're in dangerous waters here yeah and
a lot of people
now confuse the sort of thing that
you're talking about
which you know based on the way that you
describe it is undoubtedly
an anti-white or anti-western hate crime
they confuse a complaint about that
which is perfectly legitimate
with an attempt to smear people with an
attempt to attack minorities with an
attempt to
uh to be racist yeah and in one of your
previous interviews you talked about the
fact that even your parents
were worried about speaking out and
getting justice and getting you out of
that horrific situation
because your parents were worried they
would be
they're still worried about being called
now
i just ask everybody who's listening to
this or everybody who's watching this to
imagine
that this is happening to your child and
the concern you have
about being called racist is so strong
yeah
that it gets in the way of you
protecting your child
how how terrified must you be
what kind of culture you must live in to
be so scared about that that's true
that's true yeah i mean nobody is safe
victims are not safe it's been a
safeguarding disaster i would say
the fact that we're not being protected
from being falsely accused of being
racist
nazis fascists gammons
i like you said that to me i did look at
you
and also you directed the enemies bit to
me as well i saw that as well
ella's worked it all out she gave us
some she gave us two boxes of chocolates
before the show started she gave francis
the pink one and me the blue one so
she's very perceptive
i'm white so i can call you gammon get
away with it
it's a white on white cry
uh i know we shouldn't laugh i mean i
i've been
you know i've been on twitter now for
like four or five months and through
lockdown and i've
seen how bad it's getting on there and
actually i've recently left because
it's it's not it's no longer safe for me
on there yeah
the anti-fascist activists
and the online activists are really
really
vicious and really scary you know
they're they're doxxing people
the doc's two of my friends they've put
their names and dresses online they put
the kids
photographs online they're harming their
children
and you know they've hacked into
people's accounts not me personally but
i've seen that happen to other people
and
you know it's the safety concerns are
getting too high now especially when you
see all the anti-white
attacks you know the videos that have
been coming out the last few weeks
um it's horrible
just again for people yeah because most
people who may be watching this
they may not be familiar with what
you're talking about so let's just be
clear
if i was an ordinary person listening to
this interview i would say
well of course ella is going to be
a threat because the the muslims
who who may have been involved in those
grooming gangs may want revenge on her
for
speaking out or for getting them
prosecuted etc
but you are actually saying you're
shaking your head and people might not
be able to see
the the threats that are coming to you
and the people you know you were worried
about coming here
today i was scared to come here you were
scared to come here today
and you were scared i'm antifa
i just want to take a moment for people
to think about that
you're scared because the people on the
far left which is who antifa is yeah
who are caring compassionate and care
about victims and minorities and
oppressed people
uh they are the people you're worried
about
yeah the anti-fascists the anti-fascists
yeah
okay a grooming vic gang survivor
is worried about anti-fascists and and
our family members are very scared of
them
and you know
it's it's so out of hand at the moment
it's just
really really dangerous with people i
mean people are scared to have a union
jack in the garden they're scared to
um you know support england in football
they're scared to
go out and show any white skin you know
walking on the street you know they'll
cover up
every single part of them to hide the
whiteness um
people are really really worried at the
moment it's very dangerous
because the attacks are really bad but
um online
there i just wanted to come back to the
gammon thing
because um you know i get called a nazi
i get called a fascist i get called
a bigger i get called an enemy of islam
which is all lies i'm not any of those
things at all you know i'm not
anti-islam i'm not anti-muslim
i'm anti-spiritual abuse if anything but
one of the things that really hurts is
being called gammon
and the amount of times that people will
say oh you're gammon you're gammon
they'll send me
memes different memes of meat rolling
down you know
me meat rolling down a hill you know
different pictures of
pink men we said at the start that
there's not going to be any humor in
there
but you know you know that you know the
nickname they have for me is baz
barry gammon you know there's stereotype
there's pink tattooed
overweight balls headed you know typical
northern brit um
so at least you're not falling i know
she was going through all this checklist
that's me he's got he's got the better
hair tattoos are pink
yeah they are i got told by a
dermatologist in venezuela when my mum
was worried about my skin i know with
the digression we went to see
him he went to her there's nothing wrong
with your child he's just a very pink
little boy
i agree i agree nothing wrong with you
so anyway but yeah the pink meat thing
is you know we're called
easy meat yeah the girls were called
easy meat because
we're seen as being an easy target that
they can they can pick
pickles up and use those and throws away
really easily because
we're not following the strict
muslim rules where you know muslim girls
have to be chaperoned when they go out
they you know cannot look at a man who's
not the mother also their brother their
father
or their husband and if they look at a
man in the eyes then
that means that they're asking to have
sex with them
whereas if a white girl looks at a man
in a muslim man in their eyes then
she's asking him to have sex with him so
these are all the things that i was
taught
and you know believe it but so for all
these different reasons that
culturally white girls are seen as easy
meet right and you know
they sing they listen to music they like
dancing
they drink alcohol all of this is seen
as deeply immoral
and worthy of punishment and the
punishment is rape
beating so
sorry i'll just tell you who you say
they're taught this
yeah uh i i haven't read the quran
nearly thoroughly enough to be able to
speculate about that but
are you saying they're taught that by
religious scholars
basically within
we're not saying that muslims are taught
this you're saying
people in groups this is what i was
called gang ideology yes
okay like you'd say jihadi ideology
which is different to mainstream muslim
ideology or mainstream muslim belief and
actually there's a whole spectrum of
beliefs from
really really helpful to loving your
neighbor
taking care of the sick taking care of
your children protecting family
and then right across the other end of
the spectrum which is really really
harmful which is you know
bombing people and the 911 bombings the
7-7 bombings you know manchester arena
bombing and
you know punishing people for what
is perceived to be a spiritual flaw or
religious
digression right um honor killings is
included in that
so there's a whole spectrum of beliefs
and you get that spectrum within any
faith group
and when it comes to grooming gang crime
there's like five main areas so it's
virginity purity modesty obedience and
marriage
so i will talk about all the different
you know but before you do
who teaches them this this is what i'm
trying to get word of mouth from one
person to the next person
so all the generations yeah by training
younger generations and
stuff yeah okay and is it does it reside
in one particular type of community or
is it spread across
a lot of communities who who follow
islam well we don't know i don't know i
think
there may be some research that's gone
into that but
this this isn't something i know much
about i don't know much about the
different divisions
um and i would say that this is
this is spiritual abuse and even in
pakistan there's
a law against using religious scriptures
to harm people
or to use it to exploit people
sort of misusing the scriptures if you
like is is illegal in pakistan
and people can get prosecuted for that
and in fact the types of gang rapes that
you see here that are happening in
pakistan have been prosecuted as
terrorists
terrorist attacks in pakistan in
pakistan
yeah but not here no not yet
this should be they very much should be
and rape should be an act of terrorism
um and it should be included and when
police documenting evidence they should
put on there whether this person has
links to terrorist groups overseas
whether they're a returning foreign
fighter whether they are
you know part of some larger network
which is known as a
prescribed terrorist group so it
definitely needs to be treated like that
now yeah and and you were talking about
your experiences which happened 20 years
ago
are we doing enough at the moment to
protect young vulnerable girls
well that's a whole different thing and
of course you know there are lots of
perpetrators who are not pakistani
muslim
or iraqi or afghan you know these types
of gangs
and you know there's lots of white
pedophiles there's a lot of online
grooming
and you know we're not detracting from
those types of
offenses by talking about one specific
type of offense
and so one of the reasons that i've been
told to shut up for the sake of
diversity
which is a quote from a labour mp well
not from her directly she
she liked and retweeted a tweet and she
has since said that
she did that as a mistake oh she's mean
to do it
um anyway it happened
and she's not been allowed to forget it
but you know we've been told to be quiet
for
diversity for all sorts of different
reasons there are lots of different
categories of sexual offenders
um some of them use a completely
different model they do use the grooming
technique or if they do grooming there's
something called barnardo's grooming
lying which is
four main stages of like a targeting
stage where they identify
a victim and then a friendship stage
where they kind of get to know the
victim they get to know
maybe they're like puppies or they're
like kittens or they're like and then
they
like football so they'll give them
treats and presents in the line of
whatever they like
and then there's like the romantic
relationship stage where it goes into a
boyfriend girlfriend and this can be
like
20 years age gap difference um
mine was roughly 15 years and then it'll
go into
the abusive relationship stage so that's
the grooming line that's why they call
it grooming
it's nothing to do with like shaving and
having a haircut and stuff
but yeah there's all sorts of different
categories and different types of sexual
exploitation
and that are recognized within this
services um and
just because you i compare it to
medicine so if you've got a cardiac unit
it doesn't mean
you you don't care about the renal unit
but
you treat renal patients with a
different
way you know the way you need to treat
those types of diseases
different and the way that you need to
combat it is different to the way that
you need to combat
cardiac disease yeah you know and and so
there are different specialisms and you
can't say
we're taking resources from one or the
other you know you want to treat all of
it and yes it's all within the umbrella
of a big hospital
or it's all been within under the
umbrella of child
safeguarding but um there are
different approaches that are needed for
each different type so that's what i
try to do try to explain to people when
we're talking about grooming gang crime
we're not
um you know people very quickly want to
say well all races
and religions you know victims of all
races and religions
and we shouldn't be racist so you
shouldn't be biased you shouldn't
racialize the issue
um but on the other hand you know if it
is a racially religiously aggravated
crime
that needs to be dealt with in a
slightly different way and if it's
linked to terrorism
and drug trafficking and you know human
trafficking abroad or
all sorts of other you know crime
networks then
that's that that may need to be dealt
with on a different level to
you know uncle fred who's
fiddling with his nephew or whatever
it's just it's a different type of
approach needed completely i suppose
what you were getting that dummy was
whether you think that lessons have been
learned
from the experiences of people like you
and other survivors
so that it wouldn't couldn't
happen again in in the present time
in terms of the big umbrella i think the
funding is massively increased the
understanding is massively increased so
young girls in the age of 16 and not
being called child prostitutes anymore
they're being recognized as being
victims whereas they weren't for a long
time you know the police would very
often do the victim blaming alongside
the perpetrators for doing the victim
blaming
saying oh she was drunk she was wearing
a mini skirt she was asking for it
which is basically repeating grooming
gang ideology and
and ticking off the box you know
referred to counselling and
that's job done and but that doesn't
happen so much anymore and i think
there's a huge investment
going on and i've been involved in
training um professionals
about safeguarding children so
um you know been involved in a lot of
these discussions this thing has been
developing over the last few years
so and that has been improving but again
that is an overall improvement
in terms of the specialist area
again we'll wait and see what's going to
come out and what the outcomes are going
to be from
the grooming review from the home office
to see if there is going to be any
specialist provision
because what the police even have been
asking for is especially centralized
national unit
and because these drug i'm sorry the
human trafficking
is going on between county lines they
call it where it's
across borders so from one major city to
the next you know a girl can be moved
around
a lot and have perpetrators in lots of
different areas and it's very very
complex
so for the police police force point of
view
to have a centralized grooming gang unit
would be beneficial now what about the
culture
because you know when we talked about
your parents being scared
right and you know us being scared to
talk about it you
being attacked yeah do you feel that
the culture that allowed that to happen
the culture of you can't be racist
against white people
right the culture of you must be careful
not to offend different ethnic groups by
telling the truth about what's happening
that culture do you feel that we've made
enough progress on those
things i'm shocked at how bad it is
it's it's definitely going the other way
you think it's got worse it's definitely
got worse
i mean just this last few weeks i've
been
really traumatized actually really
re-traumatized because
you know when you've gone through racist
abuse and
to not have that acknowledged and then
to be told that you're racist for
reporting a racist abuse
it's another level of injustice and to
never get justice
and and then to almost be prosecuted
for speaking out about it you're feeling
that you're a threat of being prosecuted
for speaking out
and to see now you know i've i do watch
um jane james lindsay's twitter feeds
and
all all the information that's coming
out about the you know a lot of it is
feminist academics
um intersectionalist feminism
which has been
a massive spanner in the works you know
because these theories are being
put forward about you know the theories
of whiteness the theories of
white women's tears and theories of um
the why people cannot experience racism
because they've not historically been
oppressed
so you know a few months ago i was
reporting tweets to twitter saying these
are anti-white racist
tweets and i got a report back saying no
that
it doesn't breach the guidelines
twitter's guidelines so then i
reported again to another hate
organization and they contacted twitter
and came back with the reply that um
we don't remove any anti-white tweets
because white people have not been
historically marginalized or oppressed
so they're doing on twitter what the
police did 20 years ago
what the police essentially are being
taught still
still still still in some in some forces
yeah
and it doesn't exist
it goes back to that retweet shut up for
the sake of diversity
do you think we're we've been told to
shut up for the sake of diversity
yeah um and
how many well we can see it through
twitter do you think it's in every
aspect of our life where we're suddenly
felt
because of i think the the black lives
mat
black lives matter movement is
frightening to me
because a i was forced to
to bend the knee i was forced to kneel
down and kiss my perpetrator's feet i
was forced to
you know literally bend the knee to
literally kneel at his feet
as part of the abuse that i was received
and i know that other
other victims have as well from
rotherham i heard of one girl who
was forced to kneel down she was raped
by dozens of
men she was forced to lick their feet
clean
because she's white trash in their mind
she's white trash
that's that's they they're so morally
superior to
her that they believe that they are
it's a muslim superiority thing that
they believe that they have
maximum moral authority to to command
the people beneath them to do to do that
to leave their feet
so when i see the footballers kneeling
and when i see you know leading
politicians kneeling
to me they're i'm seeing them kneeling
to my perpetrators and it
breaks my heart you know i feel scared i
feel really scared that if
if this is what the police officers are
doing they're kneeling
i i understand that for them they may
feel that they're showing honor
and and that is another thing in
pakistani culture to
if a man kneels at his mother's feet and
kisses his mother's feet
he's showing honor and elevation and
he's showing how precious she is to him
and that's that is another
interpretation but
um it's also an act of subjugation to
force someone to kneel
i will make you kneel you know that kind
of you know you will
be my slave kind of thing well just just
to be clear i mean
there is some argument there uh and i
think it's important to say this that
it started with colin kaepernick taking
the knee yeah
and so some of the people who who were
taking the knee particularly in the
american context where the idea of being
knighted or
other things didn't exist it was more
sign of solidarity
than it was of of submission if you like
the problem is i think you very rightly
say is when you start
making people kneel when you start
saying
as as i'm sure would have happened if
you know we were the premier league
in this country restarted a couple of
weeks back yeah you know i'd like to see
what would have happened to a footballer
who refused to leave i know
right and that's where you come into
what you're talking about which is
you will kneel yeah you must kneel and
that troubles
troubles me i'm sure you you know
troubles you way more because you know
what that's like
and you know yeah the psychological
point of that is
domination damaging it's damaging and
it's about saying you're down there i'm
up here
so i can see why you feel that way i can
absolutely see how you feel that way
um but you brought up the the grooming
review the grooming gang review which
the government
the home office initiated uh they
prepared a report correct me if i'm
wrong at any point they prepared a
report
and that report was ready to be
published and then was not published is
that correct
yeah do you have any insight into why
it was not it was held back um
well i'm one of the people who
contributed to the review because i gave
some training at the home office and
at number 10 um so i kind of know what
some of the information that is in there
okay i also know about some of the
research that's gone into that
from one of the um feminist academics
who um is very concerned you know i know
she's personally very concerned that
this could be used as anti-muslim hate
that her data could be used um and
twisted and distorted to
to justify anti-muslim attacks
so whether that could be the reason why
they've why they were hesitant to
publish it
i'm not sure for
that particular study that was um
looking at
groups operating in networks and gangs
in the uk there were only
50 odd perpetrators that were identified
under the
specific parameters of that
investigation of that paper
um and out of those 50 odd perpetrators
i think it was 96
were um
asian and inverted commas so they were
pakistani muslim um iraqi or
afghan mostly um so again it's a very
small sample size
so to say or 96 percent of groomers
or sexual offenders are asian is
something that if you took it as just
that and didn't look at it in context
and didn't look at it in terms of you
know all the other missing data that we
don't have and we don't know
and you know all the hundreds of
thousands of other cases that
are not going through the police systems
that are not being charged
um you know we still only have like a
two percent success rate for com
for convictions for rape of any type of
perpetrator whether
black white brown asian
um so it's really really low conviction
rate anyway so there's far more
perpetrators than
vic than um convicted criminals
yeah yeah so so but sorry first let me
just
follow just on i want to first of all
get into that so
your suspicion and i don't want to put
any words in your mouth so just tell me
if any of this is incorrect
your suspicion is that they're delaying
it because they're worried
that some of the findings of the review
would be used by people to attack
muslims
yeah or that they suspect it's
inflammatory right when really i
there's no need to be concerned because
um
although there may be a few very extreme
people who might
be be inflamed to take action and
harm somebody because of that i think
most people are aware of
what the whole story now anyway you know
most
people who um who care about the
information being made public
have heard about this for a long long
time and they're
they they do believe that it's racially
religiously aggravated
and you know with any types of crime
whether it's someone getting punched in
the street or you know graffiti on
someone's house if there's a racial
religious aggravation element to it they
usually get a longer sentence it could
be slightly longer or in
severe crimes it can be double the
sentence so and that's because the
impact is
it's not just on that individual it's on
that whole identity group
community um so it is treated a lot more
seriously if it is
racially or religiously aggravated um so
i don't really see why there's
a problem because when there are
anti-muslim crimes you know we've got
organizations that give support to
victims of anti-muslim crime
that help them through the legal system
that um help bring justice to
for them and help prevent that as well
help educate and prevent
and that through through you know
teaching schools for example
um and that's fine nobody says that that
is
that when we highlight anti-muslim crime
we're
provoking um jihadi attacks or
you know terrorist attacks as missed
attacks
so we shouldn't be saying the other way
around either and ella what do you think
are going to be the long-term
implications of suppressing this report
do you think there's going to be no
implica
no implications at all do you think
they've said it's going to be released
within a year
um we'll have to see what happens now
because of
you know covered political situation the
world situation
and you know problems with
protests and things at the moment could
be making it
a difficult time to release that type of
of information
but i hope it will be released soon and
i hope they'll come up with a sensible
plan which will include
um countering the far far left
extremists who've been trying to
suppress
a lot of this information trying to
suppress that being dealt with properly
and responsibly and
and reasonably um and i hope that they
will
they will look at the spiritual aspects
and and just acknowledge that that there
that there's spiritual abuse going on
and why do you think
and i've seen this on twitter a lot
people label people who talk about the
grooming gangs issue is right wing
why do we use that term to describe
people who try and raise
yeah this issue well i'm old enough to
remember
the twin tower attacks and i think a lot
of um
a lot of this stems from that time when
you know there was a massive it was a
massive shock i was a junior
i was a medical student training
hospital and i remember i was working in
a
e department and i remember patients
saying to me you know pointing to the tv
screen and saying
you know an airplane has just flown into
one of the twin towers
in new york and i went home and
i was absolutely shaken by watching the
live footage of the people jumping out
of the building
of the whole building collapsing and i
don't know how many people died in it
horrific number three terrific number of
people
that that shook me personally because it
was um
bringing back a lot of the feelings that
i
had had being attacked um
you know by essentially islamists
who we religious extremists
so it brought back a lot of those
feelings and from that point onwards
there became this technical war on
terror and which was to
do something about all the religious
extremism teaching that was going on all
the hate preaching that was going on
within mosques
and i think that has been successful in
many ways and it has helped
to prevent
a lot more of those kind of things going
on that could have happened
um and security services have have done
that
over the last 20 years but as part of
that they've also been looking at
um far-right extremism which is a
reaction to the islamist attacks under
grooming gang crime
and lots of other things as well and
america is different
but for here it's a lot tied up to the
grooming gang issue
so when i've been to counter extremism
training and workshops and um
conferences
these two things are talked about like
it's a dichotomy like you know it's the
the upper burps versus the the var
rights and it's the muslims versus
the anti-muslim if you like so these two
groups and they've completely ignored
the far left
so if you look in the legislation and
the police guidelines in
counter-terrorism legislation
counter-terrorism efforts which is a
massive
multi-million pound industry in the uk
and multi-billion pound industry in in
america
multi-billion dollars sorry in america
so yeah that there's been this
incredible experiment which i would
i would say is it's been fired up
through
the explosion of social media
um to reduce islamist extremism and to
reduce far-right extremism
but at the expense of forgetting to
think about the far-left extremism
you know there's not been a focus for us
for a very long time and
um we're seeing now what happens if you
neglect to do something about that
and you know the far-left movements
the far-left anti-western movements
they're anti-western but for a very
different reason
would you go into that a little bit so
what why are they anti-west
why the anti-western a lot of it's
coming across it seems to be coming
across from america
from from american intersectional
feminism
and elle ellie's not a fan of the
feminism
i love you guys love you guys
i've got so many good men in my life i
just i cannot agree that all men are
misogynists and
you know i cannot agree that all men are
part of the patriarchy is just
i can't you know that's
that's a different subject sorry i
interrupted the
name you were saying it's coming over
from america which is absolutely
yeah there's there's been this um very
very well intentioned in a lot of
cases a movement against generations
of oppression of
police brutality towards black people i
mean it's
you even hear examples of it in the uk
i've got to talk about
four weeks ago the two black women that
were murdered in a park nearby here
where we're recording
um we think they're from a christian
family background but we don't know if
there's a religious or a racist
intent to why they were murdered but um
it's possible it was and that is that's
under investigation by the police now
but
one of the most shocking things is that
police officers
took selfies of themselves with the
bodies
of these two murdered women and
you know things like this
you know when you hear stories like that
you can see how
or you can understand how the pain
of you know generations of being
disrespected for the color of your skin
being treated as less than human because
the color of your skin
is it has brought up this black lives
matter movement
and because it's it's for anyone to be
dehumanized to be treated like an animal
essentially or just a worthless piece of
trash is
totally wrong we're all valuable every
one of us is valuable
and that's what you can't say now
actually we can't say that if we
um with the way that the black lives
matter movement has
has now been pressed to such
a degree and condensed and built up in
this cauldron with
you know the socialist aspect the
communist aspect the marxist
aspect new marxism aspect the islamist
aspect
you know all these different political
viewpoints but all of it anti-western
all about anti-white um and it's just
hit boiling point in this cauldron at
the moment i think with lockdown it
made it worse and kind of existential
crisis of are we all gonna die of
coronavirus
you know there's a threat that we will
under the moment
um that it's really
and
what i see on social media is that that
hasn't been silenced at all
so i know we talk about free speech and
i've moved over to tapala
now where it's meant to be anything goes
you can say what you like it can be
defensive as you like and you won't be
censored it's really civilized it's
really polite everyone's very nice i
don't see
you know i don't see the racist abuse i
don't see i'm
sure there is someone there but i
haven't really experienced it last week
since i've been on there
um whereas on twitter when you you know
you've got this
it is it's more sense sensorous that
but it's also more abusive um and the
abuse is definitely directed to
to anyone who's being too westernized or
too is seen to be
sort of um what do you call it upholding
the patriarchy or
in collusion in collusion with white
supremacists yeah or whatever
and as you said they're they're allowed
by twitter to do it because when you
complain about it they they ignore it
absolutely
the i think the issue that a lot of
people have with twitter
is the double standards if they had
equal standards for everybody
and they they said look this is a
non-abusive platform the moment you
start being abusive to people
it doesn't matter white black yellow
whatever yeah you get banned or you get
blocked or you get suspended
or or equally they could say we don't
care every you can say whatever you want
yeah
and then if they treated everybody
equally i think people would would take
it at face value and they would go
i don't want to be on an abusive
platform yeah or
i'm happy to be on a censorious platform
as long as it's fair
yeah the issue that you're raising is
not fair it's not fair no it's not
balanced
but for some people in a lot of movement
it's fair because it's been so
outweighted against them for so long
that they feel that for it to be
outwitted against
white people it's only balance and
that's why they would call it satire
you know this is funny to repeatedly
abuse someone calling gammon calling
them meat
calling them you know you because you
because you're color of the skin you're
worthless you're
you're nothing better than just a piece
of slab of meat you know that's funny
it's not funny
no it's absolutely not funny it's very
insulting and
what are the long-term implications of
do you think of allowing this sort of
very much
very hard leftist neo-marxist way of
thinking not not censoring them
they can come in they can say whatever
they like they can be verbally abusive
what do you think of the long-term
implications of that well history tells
us it's not good
really not good and we look at world
different systems around the world and
we learn it's really not good um
but you know as i talk about
identity-based
violence and identity-based abuse um
and i say that we need to we need to
understand what that is and realize that
we are victims of it
but i talk about free speech
and i know this is a whole call for free
speech and everything and
i'm saying well hold on we need free
speech but with safe boundaries
you know we have these speech laws for a
reason you know we have a computer act
to say that it's wrong to hack into
people's computers and steal the data or
their lives or the money or whatever and
it's wrong to slander people
or it's wrong to libel people and it's
wrong to aggressively troll people you
know we've got these laws
they need to be applied but they need to
be applied to the far left
because we've got the far right the far
left and the upper verbs
so the way that i have come to
understand
how these how to explain this to people
is that they were extremists want
to attack your mind your body and your
spirit
okay they want control over your mind
your body and your spirits and we've all
got a mind and a body and a spirit
and the far-right extremists are kind of
experts in controlling and
taking um approaching you from
controlling your body and controlling
physical violence physical strength
physical power
the far i'm sorry the up above
extremists are more
interested in controlling your spirit so
they'll use
you know they'll use guilt and shame
they'll use religious manipulation
they'll use religious scriptures to
control you to get you to do what you
want what they want you to do to serve
them
and then there's a far left extremists
who are experts in the mind and
controlling the mind and they will
attack your mind
and they will do that through social
media they will do that through
social norms or do it through um you
know
pseudoeducation a lot of there's also
manipulation of language
the language yeah yeah and they are the
experts yeah
yeah you know you've heard the saying
that the the devil is a lawyer
yes i do think of that quite often yes
the skill of these people to flip things
and manipulate things and
get the wording and change the
definition of things like change the
definition of racism to me
to mean that all 50 different races in
the world can be victims of racism or
apart from one that's white people it's
nonsense
absolutely nonsense and i
mean you you brought up to far left to
far right and up above
and i think most people understand uh
you know the up above the religious
stuff we kind of all get i think um the
one thing i wanted to ask you about as
well is
you know you're very sensible and
reasonable and you don't want
anyone to be hated or mistreated or
anything like that
do you feel that there's been
because of maybe the lack of proper
coverage of the issue of grooming gangs
it has fallen on to the shoulders you
might say of people who
who some of whom may be leaning towards
the far right let's say
to speak up on that issue and that's
kind of where the problem i think for a
lot of people comes in now which is like
oh you're talking about grooming gangs
you must be far right like that's the
connection people often make and you
talk about how you
get called all those things do you think
that's just a convenient
label or do you think there is some
truth that that was an issue that was
taken up by some people who were far
right
was i think there's individual cases and
individual grievances and
people who are interested in this in the
topic of grooming gangs
are very often personally affected by it
so either them or a family member
has been a victim of it and that
includes the men because there are male
victims of grooming gangs as well
and of all backgrounds and races
so whether certain individuals have
have exploited the issue as as people
would say
for personal gain i find that wording
i find i'm uncomfortable with that
particular wording of it because
for people who are fighting for justice
and have been fighting for justice for a
very long time
um who might be seeking funding to get
justice
or to be seeking funding to raise
awareness and
even if they're doing it in a not very
helpful way
or a potentially harmful
racist or destructive way
to label every one of them as far right
i think you need to look at each
individual case as it is when you're
looking at
extremism you know the definition of
extremism is someone who
is justifying violence to
fulfill their religious social or
political
objective um so that is what extremism
is
and so if they're not looking for
violent solutions to
the problem of grooming gangs then you
can't really call them extremist far
right
and they're probably just normal people
a lot of them yeah and
how much do you think young girls have
been deemed
expendable because they're from a
working class background
as in yeah i mean it's a horrible
question to ask
because i presume from what i've read
this doesn't
didn't apply to a lot of middle-class
girls these were predominantly
working-class girls
yeah vulnerable girls so the authorities
therefore thought
not as important there are a lot of
middle class victims
there are because um believe it or not
middle class people get scared
and get intimidated just as much as
anybody else
so it's really not hard once
perpetrators picked
a victim they don't really care what a
family are like
because they know that they've got guns
they've got weapons they've got a whole
gang of
violent people who are going to make
threats and
intimidate the girl even just
threatening to kill her dog kill her cat
you know she's going to be scared enough
to go along and do with whatever they
say
especially if you know there's part of a
love element in it as well where she
feels like she's loving them and
there's some romantic relationship going
on
but yes you're right there is a lot of
um there are a lot of victims from
working-class
families um
a lot of families that live in close
proximity to a lot of these
group groups where the gangs live um
it's impacted them a lot harder and
you know male family members within
groups have been through the same
similar school system with similar
problems with gangs you know they've
they've been beaten up they've been
attacked and
different things and stabbed for having
a muslim girlfriend and that type of
you know problem which all links into
the same
issue or you know they've been
got into drug dealing at a very young
age by these gangs who use them as
runners
to deal drugs um whether
their voices are not being heard perhaps
they're not as articulate
perhaps they can't express things um
of course people just don't want to
listen to them or they're too scared to
speak out
and also a lot of them do think that
they are racist
because the police are telling them
they're racist you know i heard a story
a couple weeks ago
of a survivor very recently who um
the police have said she can't give
evidence because she's racist
because she called her perpetrators
pakis
in the interview in the video interview
so just saying that word saying that
word
has meant her evidence has been thrown
out and look i mean
it's a racial slur but as i said earlier
in the interview
if you've gone through the experience
that she's gone through i mean you can
understand somebody in my heart with
some prejudice and
i i wouldn't put it past myself to
harbor prejudice against people who
targeted me
on the basis of my identity called me
jewish this and whatever
right or in your case white you know
no i'm not saying people should go
around calling each other pakis i'm not
saying that but
but if you're the police officer in that
situation you've got to have some idea
of balance
in the situation you know yeah that's
crazy
that's crazy but i think again it's that
it's this if you don't if you don't deal
with the far left who are branding it's
like you've been tired and feathered if
you've been tired and feathered as being
racist
gammon nazi fascist you know far-right
then you are rubbish basically so
if you don't deal with this issue that
we've got this problem
we've got this fake branding of people
and and demonization of white people
who are raising this issue then you're
going to get people afraid to deal with
it and that does include police officers
they're going to be afraid of being
tired and feathered the judiciary are
going to be afraid of being tired of
feathers so they're not going to want to
touch it
you know politicians are going to be
afraid of being tired and feathered
they're not going to
want to be involved in dealing with this
because it's such like a hot potato at
the moment they're going to want to pass
it on to somebody else
but it's an abdication of responsibility
your job as a police officer is to
investigate and to charge
rapists and the people committing these
awful crimes yeah
and it's not hard all they've got to do
is say it's a racially religiously
aggravated rape
they are the perpetrators of the racists
yeah that's all they've got to do
right and we and we don't and and also
equally
the other thing i mean even if you are
racist you can still be raped right you
can be racist and be raped
right those are not mutually exclusive
things right so even if someone is
you know yeah they use the word [ __ ]
i mean she may have used that word
because they were using that word about
themselves right i don't know where
she's got that from
yeah i just i just listen to what
everything you're telling us and
i have no words i have no words to
and i don't understand i think a lot of
people would feel that way
listening and watching how how is this
possible how is it have we got to the
situation
yeah and i suppose at some level the
question that a lot of people be asking
and i know that you work with
with the government towards it you know
how do we solve this
keep talking about it you know
there are things that are worrying me
like these um
diversity inclusion and and the quality
panels that have been set up in every
company and every business
um i think we need to be aware that they
they must be balanced
they must include the anti-white
anti-western racism as a form of
discrimination that needs to be counted
as well as all the other
forms of discrimination you know we need
to not make it
a crime for someone to say all lives
matter
um and for people not to be persecuted
and attacked
even for saying white lives matter you
know when i saw that banner
going over the stadium i can't help but
i did feel loved
that was my reaction i felt loved and
for people who've who have maybe
just recently discovered that one of
their family members believes that all
white lives matter or that white lives
matter
and now they've they've or or one of the
colleagues in their
department believes that white lives
matter you know and they
they're shocked and horrified by that
fact you know that by that belief
hopefully listening to people like me
listening to interviews like this
they'll understand that that's not
coming from a place of hatred or malice
and it's not a counter
attack on the black lives matter
movement it's it's a
parallel justice movement
you know the justice for the white
victims of racism is a parallel movement
to the justice for black victims of
racism
and we can do that together and we can
be united together we don't have to be
split apart we're divided in that we can
we can all be supportive of each other
yeah it's it's very interesting you say
that and then you know
again we come from we work in a very
woke industry and i see people sharing
books like you know we used to work in
the very work industry i haven't been
offered one gig for the last few months
anyway it doesn't matter
um you're in high demand
in other ways but so for instance
sharing books you know like white
fragility you know what you know and
spreading you know
the memes and the it doesn't help does
it really as to
that particular book i haven't read it
yeah so i probably can't comment on it
but from what i've heard
it's it's upholding what i would call
grooming gang ideology
so it's upholding the idea that white
people are trash that white people
should be punished
that's from what i've heard in the book
original sin yeah
yeah that it's an original sin to be
born why it's something you cannot
change you cannot get rid of
and that you have to atone for that in
service to other people in service to
people of color
and that is basically grooming ideology
see this is
why you see the thing with the white
lives matter thing
is that if it was being used in the way
that you use it
i i'd agree with you but i think there
are also people who use it as a kind of
fu to the black lives matter thing as
well
and this is the reason that we've
opposed identity politics from the start
because once you start going down this
rabbit hole
of going this is a special group and
this is a special group and that's a
special group and that's
but these people they're not special at
all in fact they need
then you get into trouble because
eventually you know helen dale who we
had on the show you know she said
i remember saying this in in the 90s you
know if you're going to have gay pride
at some point someone's going to go we
need straight pride
yeah and this is the problem with with
all of this and this is the far left
that you talk about that's where it all
comes from this this
ideology of getting everybody into their
own little group and now why people need
to advocate for themselves
that's not you know you talk about
history not a healthy recipe
not a healthy recipe we need to go back
to this idea that people are individuals
you know and you can be racist against
anyone including white people
but but this idea of pushing everybody
into their own group
that's not going to work you know it's
obvious that america hasn't been taught
about the white slave trade
but even in the uk a lot of people have
never heard of the white slave trade
they've never heard of the berber
slave trade um and the you know the
barbary slave trade and the berbers in
north africa that attacked
europe for centuries taking slaves away
and to be trafficked throughout um
northern africa
into um asia
and the arab slave trade you know white
slaves were very valuable to them they
were sort of seen as
exotic prized possessions and
taken into harams and you know
sold and used and you know so that that
has been happening and white people have
been
exploited and and enslaved
so to say that white people don't
understand it don't
know what it's like you know i've got a
friend that i know through twitter and
then
i've read her book and and she was
trafficked to northern
africa um my grandfather was taken to
germany as a slave laborer
this the way we talk about slavery is
just completely historical
we don't take into account the middle
east and arab
slave traders took more black slaves out
of africa than
than the colonial powers did we don't
talk about the fact that slavery's been
a constant through history
look people in my country in russia were
serfs until like 1870 or something
you know as i said slave laborers in
germany
yeah like 70 years ago right the way we
talk about it is ridiculous
we and and we pretend that it's this
unique moment in history when in fact
right now is a unique moment in history
even though there is more slaves
having said that about taking statues
down yeah
you know i did post out a tweet that you
know i was actually
quite i quite enjoyed seeing the group
take down the course and
yeah the edward holston statue because
he was a known slave trader and you know
you know there's if you don't understand
the history of bristol
and that a lot of money came through
the slave trade and to making a lot of
their schools a lot of buildings a lot
of the town hall type
places and named after edward coulston
who did a lot of
philanthropy and a lot of good things as
well but
the um people wanting to dis
people in bristol wanting to distance
themselves from that history and wanting
to make that break
and make that symbolic gesture of we
don't support slavery
we do not want that to be a symbol of
who we are
as a country i i can support that
and i did you know
as an artistic creative act you know
in your industry you could see you know
these there's a long tradition of this
type of thing
i'm not talking about taking down every
statue in the whole country
this is a very different issue but in
selected cases where it's a
public demonstration of a cleansing if
you like of getting rid of
part of the past that we no longer feel
part of and we want to reject we want to
move away from
i can see that that could be healing for
a lot of people
you know but what do you replace it with
you do not replace it with
a white trash concrete statue did you
see the one that they replaced it with
no
no it's um it's a barry garman it's a
white overweight
guy oh that one oh that's perfect right
yeah
yeah so you don't treat it you don't
replace it with
an insulting disrespectful hateful
piece of art that is treating people
like trash
you don't replace it with that that you
you respect everybody and you value
everybody
that that's what you need to replace it
with something that shows that we are
all important yes and we
every life is precious as you know we we
have one more question that we always
ask our guest at the end but before we
do i just wanted to tell you
very briefly the story of how i first
really kind of
became we both i think became awake to
this issue in in the way that we did
because i read a little bit about it and
then i saw sarah champ
champions article the mp for rotherham
and she wrote an article i think in one
of the tabloids about this
about this issue and
the article is quite sensible i thought
based on reading it but she got
horrible backlash and this was probably
a year until i was doing trigonometry
and i emailed her to invite her onto the
show
and she replied back saying she didn't
feel comfortable talking about it
anymore and that's when i went
okay look we're comedians we're bothered
about political correctness because it's
a nuisance to us
and you know at some kind of conceptual
level
we can think about you know it's a
principle of witnesses
all of this [ __ ] really you know
abstract [ __ ]
but then when i got that email from her
and i was talking to francis on the
phone about i was like
no no political correctness yeah is
preventing
a member of parliament yes from standing
up for people like you
definitely and that's when i was like
you know this is a serious
problem that we've got here yeah and
it's very difficult to talk about
and it's you know for an mp to be scared
about it tells you everything about it
so
i just want to say on behalf of
everybody's listened and watch this
how courageous you are and how much we
appreciate coming on the show thank you
and same
to you as well you're very courageous
and i really appreciate you
we're just stupid
thank you so much and all power to you
and i hope the work that you do with the
government
leads to the positive change so maybe
actually before we ask you the last
question
one thing maybe that is good for us to
ask is if anyone's watched this or they
listen to this
yeah you know if they've been affected
by what advice would you give them if if
they know someone who's been affected by
what advice would you give them if they
don't know if they're not affected
personally
and a family member isn't but they just
want to do something positive
too you know to prevent it from
happening in the future to help people
who've been through it
what can people do you know i would say
to all the people who are feeling like i
am right now who are feeling doubly
attacked
not just attacked from their attackers
but also from the left
i would say hang in there wait
be patient don't retaliate don't think
you have to go and
fight for your country fight for
whatever don't be violent
don't you know set up armies and
put yourself at risk and be patient hang
in there because
the government will respond the police
will respond they will wake up
and i do have faith that they will
understand that this is far-left
terrorism
you know as as antifa's been designated
the terrorist organization in america it
eventually that is going to happen here
for people like you don't despair
you're going to be in demand because you
know how to
create great education great content to
counter a lot of this far left
extremism whether that's in schools or
in comedy clubs or whatever you
you do it's going to be needed just hang
in there
thank you hang in there and ella the
last question
that we always end our interviews with
is what's the one thing that we're not
talking about
but we really should be
i think we're not talking about how to
recover from spiritual abuse
and that there can be recovery and that
you can heal
and that people can
get out of it and get up again
you know you can be knocked down many
many times you can be knocked down
in many ways but you can always get up
again
and that's a really really powerful
message to on the interview with
ella thank you so much for coming if
people want to find you on social media
is it parlour that you're on now
yeah i'm well i'm i'm on twitter but i'm
not active on there but there's a lot
they can read on my pinned tweets
there's lots of threads on there they
can read about
all the different messages i'm putting
out but yeah i'm on par
now ella hill dr ella hill dr ella hill
well thank you so much for coming on
and thank you very much for watching um
it's been
a really emotional episode and just to
focus back on that if
at any point if you've been affected by
these issues
or if something has happened to you
along these lines
please talk to somebody about it um and
we will hopefully see you
soon with another fantastic episode
thank you very much you went really down
and then straight back up again
you've been affected by this we'll see
you another brilliant episode
thanks very much thank you so much thank
you
thanks for watching guys as always
subscribe to the youtube channel
click the bell button next to subscribe
button so you get notified when a video
comes out
and follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod
and also leave us a nice review on
itunes and spread the word